today's one minute Monday is take time
to reflect so many times as
entrepreneurs we have these big goals
right we have this big vision for what
we want to accomplish and when we don't
see the huge momentum to get there we're
not hitting our goals yet we get
discouraged we get down on ourselves we
wonder if it's ever gonna happen for us
and what often helps is to take a little
bit of time to reflect on everything
that you have done so far and the growth
that you have had so far so here's a
great example I was looking at my
numbers for YouTube and I was looking at
how many views I got for the past month
and last month was my best month yet we
had over 300,000 views on the YouTube
videos thank you guys for that and I got
a little discouraged because I'm like ah
300,000 is still nothing I want to be at
like 3 million a month I want to get
there that's my bigger goal I want to
reach more people with my message but
then I look back on the year and where
it was last month versus the year before
and a year before I only had 50,000
views a month and now I'm at 300,000
views a month that's a huge increase
year-over-year
and yes it's not where I want to be yet
and yes having that big goal helps drive
me forward but also reflecting on the
growth that has happened and the things
that I've done to get better helps give
me a little more encouragement so the
next time you feel down the next time
you feel like you haven't hit your goal
yet the next time you feel like you're
little discouraged about your business
look look back and reflect on some of
the things you have done and the
progress that you have made because
it'll impress you and they'll give you a
little bit encouragement to keep going
and to keep believing don't forget to
check out my newsletter below hi I'm
Jason Grif on sigur rós online.com and I
want to say Evan Carmichael's newsletter
is consistent fun inspiring and it's
only newsletter I prioritize and look
forward to period